de porte en porte dans le quartier du
pont du rotois rats guyancourt françois
morton maire sortant de la commune est
parti à la rencontre des habitants pour
présenter son programme et sa liste
guyancourt pour tous bonjour madame
françois morton maire de guyancourt
on vient à la rencontre des habitants
vous pouvez nous ouvrir la porte
ce programme il est prêt puisqu'il a été
distribué dans l'ensemble des boîtes aux
lettres de la ville de guyancourt la
semaine dernière donc dans les douze
mille boîtes aux lettres de la ville
ce programme il est il est issu d'un
certain nombre de constats qui ont été
effectués durant tout le mandat dernier
mais aussi et bien évidemment du travail
qu'on a pu faire en collaboration avec
les habitants
lors de nos ateliers citoyens du mois de
novembre un programme proposé en trois
grandes parties
tout citoyen tout solidaire et vivre
tous ensemble avec douze thématiques et
une centaine de points précis comme la
construction de logements adaptés à tous
les revenus
l'extension de la faculté de médecine
sur la commune ou encore la rénovation
de nouvelles voiries
certaines sont tout à fait transversales
comme par exemple la transition
écologique dans toutes ses dimensions
d'ailleurs environnemental mais aussi
social et économique
alors vous avez la tranquillité publique
vous avez l'éducation bien évidemment
qui reste un pilier fort de notre
programme
et puis toutes les questions sont
abordées en n'éludant aucune
le programme est à retrouver dans les
boîtes aux lettres en attendant françois
morton donne rendez vous aux guyancourt
toi le 3 mars prochain pour une nouvelle
réunion publique